all right
it is 2019 all the marathon part two i
streamed what i streamed at 8 a.m. it's
not 1 p.m. there are just under 6 hours
left in the tournament i don't think
i'll stream the whole 6 hours but let's
join and see what happens
actually rejoining I'm in 318 place I
have a winning streak lost 2 games so
far in this event
ok and I'm keeping the rule if my
opponents below 2000 lb zerk but this
opponent is 2006 so I won't beserk let's
play Bishop b5 check so lion that I've
played in tournaments in the past
haven't played recently though I'll go
for Marazzi mine setup this is one of
the the main approaches because I've
trade off traded off my light squared
Bishop and my pawns are in light square
is the rest of the minor pieces are
actually quite quite happy it's a nice
setup
it's like definition of Marazzi mind
right here I'll play off three cuz
always play off three probably play b3
too but maybe not necessary play King h1
missed improving moves rook c1 defending
the pawn with tactics at Queen Jake c4 I
have 95 attacking e7
like Queen Queen d2 is interesting some
idea of Knight d5 yeah like you're 95
essentially forces Queen d8 not sure if
I'm getting so much and I get the dark
squared bishop maybe I'll start with b3
I do want to make a 95 work okay not
gonna happen
let's play Queen f2 this position
requires patience is waiting for the
right opportunity to to strike I'll play
play Knight d2 maybe at some point I can
trap the Queen g4 9 f4 ideas actually
whoa 93 that was a blind spot I did not
see that move okay that's a wake-up call
only losing a rook Belgian novice in the
chats first person and the chat welcome
welcome
can I have to rebound only down the
exchange could be worse
d5 was d5 can i play this move there's
Queenie 525 93
[Music]
some forcing lines is Pawnee 5:20 xe5
busy before don't think that's great
there's also g4 here on g4 could be
interesting
g4 here Bishop f4 traps the Queen and
then if Queen h3 h3 can be a problem we
need to be a queen of two takes not
seeing how this works
I'll find out off for some idea of
Queenie 593 Queen moves back 'if I've
try and go for the space grab the Queen
was to c7 I have x-ray vision
I've Queen goes to d6 I have a fork it's
a little bit tricky for a black Queen a7
bust move I have Bishop f4 I might be
forcing Queen eight okay so I'm getting
comp that's all I want for Christmas
even though it's not Christmas yet he
five may be coming you taking on d5
actually this could be just a free pawn
box gonna play b5 and then they have d6
let's do this
in Queen d4 looming I'm controlling the
center John Davis is back quicker than
he thought yeah I'm walking into some
some stuff but I'm controlling the
center black's queen is in the corner
well the lady six if it works not sure
if it threatens anything because a deep
pons pinned and now the D pons attacked
so let's move it it's getting weird
bishop f8 play bishop
no not Bishop g5 maybe rook d1 this very
tricky situation Knight e5 no not sure
what to do here I think I'll play rogue
do you want I'm looking at Queen c6
Bishop e5 takes takes takes Queen G 494
later it's something I defend the knight
to which is important so defending
attacking 97 maybe night before I have
to get some initiative yeah so this is
what I was calculating hope it's not
that bad of 95 immediately that could be
interesting defiles pretty cluttered the
idea is to do this
and destroy the opponent's if there
should be five I fork everything Wow
so problem is my Queens attacked so it's
still tricky I mean I should start with
this I think maybe I should start by
taking let's start by taking their their
some back rank issues in the end I
always take on e5 - this is tricky oh I
forgot about that move no I don't think
I've messed up no I have 93 okay still
kind of alive almost flag - there I no
no no this is not gonna end well
wait what wait what Wow
rook c1 rook d1 check I'm winning how am
i winning this opponent has blundered
safety first
loofa the my beautiful streak almost
died but now it's still alive let's push
pawns I'll still have to break through
let's just try and trap the rook
yeah a g5 is the killer blow a very
fitting killer blow pawn is pinned maybe
I'll start with this improve a little
bit just go after the pawn walk the King
in okay take upon yeah why not
Queen g7 incoming what a game such a
long game too
oh man I mean I was I was dead but then
I came back to life we just go back yeah
93 Queen dxd threes good move all black
needs to do is move King g8 Queen g4
King h8 and loose Queen d6 was tricky
but yeah after rook c1 I have the
discovered check okay hello to everyone
haven't said hello to too many people we
have a lot of people we have someone
from Honduras we have diamond cutter a
long time no see
life is good especially after that game
you got Jess thanks for bits
privyet two doubles Don's bonza and
Shawn of game hello Kevin hello okay
let's buzzer
Oh volume is loud Kings gambit I'm Faulk
your counter gambit
toxic but now the party hello this looks
Pleasant Queenie - yeah so this is some
preparation Paul ah thanks for the bits
I appreciate that
Knight c3 I think is considered dubious
easy bishop g1 thanks for subbing so 95
yeah what's the move to play here play
Bishop f5 I don't have too much time to
think
good take let's just take I'm Bishop e6
I'm pretty sure I had this exact
position against John Davis at some
point in time I remember the bishops
doing work so material is equal somehow
but I have apology for e3 ideas looming
III could potentially win a pawn I mean
maybe I should have played that last
move let's stick with let's actually
take with pawn actually I'm indecisive
let's say with pawn I didn't want to
allow Bishop c4 if pawn c4 and I just
Bishop e6 or even III with a
counterpunch have I tried roti is it
roti Jala or roti challah is a Indian
bread I've had roti I had roti in
Singapore it was delicious
um b4 yeah I have to move a lot faster
if g3 III tactics
those pawns hard to defend c4 might
happen
c4 Bishop e6 okay free pawn some up a
pawn but down on time
put the rook somewhere happy this is a
passed pawn this is active rook I want
to play rook f8 just apply pressure
bishops tied down to this pawn there's
an e6 preventing work t7 so rip d2
probably expected and then this
threatening the bishop bishops a bit
stuck still Kings also stuck I might
just be able to squeeze white make some
orange juice or just promote a pawn oh I
love Bishop d3 though mmm
should be three visual d3 roti - maybe
do you want to take h7h - I always have
to look for like promotion tactics so
rook a - it could be appealing slaver
okay - both pawns hanging probably want
to take a three and keep attacking stuff
if Ricky one rook a one there should be
one Bishop f5 should win King bee - we
trade and then e to an end can take
something let's start with this and then
take or is that yeah I guess I'll go for
this no the pawn III is it can't really
be attacked controlling all these
squares I'll just walk my king up I just
have to take all the ponds and queen and
and enough time in 26 seconds probably
go after the Queen side pawns play h6
for good measure
so everything on dark squares except my
lights for a bishop gonna play this okay
nice relatively clean
[Music]
took a little bit of effort in that game
okay
top 300 1111 or actually 111 getting
carried away quite English have not
played in English this stream c6 play
play what I used to play of a Slav
without d4 Queen b3 looks interesting
mmm play 95 have no idea if this is
theory but it looks playable not sure
what to do here some weird idea Queen
takes b3 bishop see - if pawn d3 looks
weird though
I'm just gonna develop develop castling
don't think I can go wrong with that
f4 maybe yeah for looks enticing trying
to take on e5 each 5 ok opponents also
being ambitious the Queen's are getting
traded hmm what to do could take
want to reinforce a five takes
let's take once d3 not sure what to do
here I've incremented so I can think
each 3G for ideas could commit to d4
maybe I will commit to d4 and Bishop
seems really sad but the idea is Bishop
d2 hey Lu - GG thanks for subbing yeah
the idea is to just use the bishop to
support this B pawn push there's a game
Janowski Capablanca like nine early
1900s it reminds me of like this plan
the BB pawns like pushing forward 95
eventually it's due ambition t1 so this
lights not an outpost because f6 could
happen
but yeah do keep the chat in english
porfavor pizzelles - please let's play
Knight c5 okay I like the structure now
this could be a long grind
it's very positional I could sack stuff
but I like my minor pieces too much
let's play Bishop a5 first I don't want
to go insane too early maybe g3 some
idea of like King G to h3 eventually g4
oh there's another idea here - an idea
here that sometimes comes up in the
London and these structures to play rook
b4 and then bring the other rook to b3
could trade bishops do I want to trade
not sure
[Music]
yeah I think I'll trade because the rook
has to take and then I have this move
Bishop c8 looks forest and then let's
play Bishop f3 first the knight moves in
I might just take it I think the plan is
to play this this this this and then
just get some get some travel in build
up the credit card points for the night
the airline miles
let's do its this move defending e3 okay
now I can take Oh H 2 is kind of
backwards I have 95 here point 95 not an
easy position to win rookie h1 would
like to somehow prepare rook H 1 H 4
okay let's start with this yeah like
rook h8 I might just play h4 takes and
then g4 and then win the pawn eventually
you know the pawns should be falling
someday f6 coming rook b3
yeah rook is multi-purpose on b3 so the
first step is to win the H pawn should
be pretty straightforward
then eventually like further down the
road I want to do this get rid of this
pawn plant the knight back on e5 okay so
let's just take a pond oh no I should
have taken with night oh but it's not
that bad because I can take on b7
there's Bishop takes g4 no but is it bad
I guess I'll find out I have King g3
should keep me alive
we're gonna have some brook ending it's
getting it's getting interesting
King f2 probably my Brook is active
these pawns are potentially weak
ok now I can take and gather ninety five
so just have I'll start with this
I've ways to attack c6 with the rook
grew up e6 coming
I just want to get rid of this pawn and
then queen my C pawn oh no I can't do
that uh what did I do
mm-hmm
this is tricky rook c7 maybe my time is
dwindling Oh No
check oh this is really bad
oh this is so bad I just lost everything
okay I need another miracle
we're g3 was the worst move I lost a
game I was just out playing my opponents
and then terrible things happened
yeah the king should just go to g3 I
don't know why I played kini - oh that's
sad got careless a little bit tired I
have to wipe away my tears that's life
third loss of the tournament lost some
rating points okay let's come back
Nova's working where as a coffee I have
tea mint green tea happy Halloween
98 yeah Bishop c4 Queen f3 down the
piece but I haven't made threats I think
I want to play h4 h4 h5 also ideas of
Bishop g5 mg v f6 it's interesting a
bishop a three-two
yeah there are some moves to consider
what to do maybe King f1 just getting
off the the file yeah King f1 yeah where
is box Queen going because f6 f6 I just
take in wind stuff Queen a3 I take so
Queen f8 probably only move play rook e1
feels like black is suffering I [ __ ] is
very much stuck in this position despite
being up a piece it is a question though
like what is White's plan there's no
immediate like targets like okay black
wants to play b6 in Bishop e7 so I think
the plan is to play f4 f5 I also play d5
immediately like d5 d6
so maybe what I can do
start with Queen d3 preventing b5 a long
enough pawn to move forward and also if
I get in this then the F pawn is tied
down to the night so the question is do
I play a4 or d5 both look very
attractive I'll play d5 I think this is
very direct like the Kings just stuck in
the center the Queen's on f8 e 6 is very
hard to stop hello to Elvin spell and
hello to past life karma if you just got
here yeah this is a Halloween gambit
celebrating Halloween early
trying to have some fun trying to
recover from the previous game black can
legally castle kind of forgot about that
but black castles I probably just take
em oh it's interesting huh oh I have a
nice idea to take y'all take first does
it kind of does it work
wait a minute
it's complicated also have a 7 e7 d6
yada yada I can also take on each six on
so many options not sure
I'm trying to calculate takes
[Music]
let's take your first it was difficult
decision
okay now d6 unleashing the bishop oh I
got mated I got mated where'd that come
from
I got made had no idea block of sweating
meat had no awareness of my weakness
what was that that's so tragic I was
debating between d6 and Queen takes in
Bishop III even like this move is a boon
Oh two losses in a row yeah Halloween
gambit refuted okay let's recover
recovery time I'll play Sicilian okay
time atif just for the toxic banana
party I'll play the line with h5 I've
played this a few times in tournaments
I'm trying not to get tilted but that
last game was kind of tilting I have to
stay calm at least I'm still above 2,500
each three
each 3-play h5 no it's um let's take and
play this Bishop f4 was interesting move
to h4 here okay it's getting interesting
how many points do I have think 111
anti-tilt bits thanks so much
Queen g3 is exotic but then Bishop e3 I
don't know if it does that much can I do
this move takes h3o Bishop e3 I can take
all right I'll play Queen g3 just for
for giggles if the Queen retreats and I
think I can take and play this and win I
should pre move this I should have
played EF in that last game yeah so many
of other things I could have done
I think I've uh I've mesmerized my
opponent with my my queen it's so
hypnotic on g3 okay the trade ooh
Bishop III so I could take on f2 it's
probably most logical we could trade
everything and then we just have some
and game but do I want to to take I
think I do
then d6 and King e7 radiates have to
hold on tight
he 598 he got barely hold on z nation
chess z nation chess has a first badge I
saw this in another stream I think this
means a very first subscriber also if
you hover over it it says founder I
still need a or maybe I don't need I was
gonna say I need a two-year sub badge
but you have the first badge which is
probably the most powerful the things C
nation for stopping by yet again yeah
it's been about two years since I
started streaming consistently on Twitch
and z nation was there from the very
beginning
okay so White's trying to figure out how
to destroy me all I want to do is have
some fun whoa what is this 94 I can take
and rook v8
I don't really have any weaknesses I'm
just passive maybe someday I'll be
passive-aggressive I wanna play b6 or
actually I want to do this in this and
just trade how can I join chats says the
person in the chat I think you figured
it out so if I if I play this and
there's Mike c5 and I don't want to do
that
I played b6 just preparing this yeah
slowly untangling and now what where
does my knight want to be the trick is
in these situations you figure out the
square the knight wants to be and then
you figure out how to get there I'm
actually gonna start with this move
actually no my knight wants to be
undecided where it's a it defends it has
access to center squares and then I want
to play rook c7 b5 also White is very
low on time I'm b5 right away play this
first
what to do I play b5 oh there's a threat
though I should not lose a pawn let's
play this move
maybe f5 nah weakens d5 maybe a 5 I
don't know what to do f6 always play off
6 and then 9 f7 and I'll just kind of
Cocoon and I'll reroute the rook to
attack the H pawn
there's my g5 here attack the H pawn
again can control the D file attack the
H pawn again aha now G pawns kind of
backwards hard to exploit though maybe
I'll play g6 at some points yeah open
the H file hopefully in my favor
and now return
okay have some activity preventing g5
aha
hey rook g2 would be a blunder I have to
take I don't want to take but I have to
okay so there's a few plans here this is
one plan this is another plan does this
win this might know it's it's
interesting it might be winning let's
try it
King pawn ending two pawns fixes three
pawns question is how do I make progress
I can walk around if before I take this
way and I'm still in the box
yeah I saw that coming
[Music]
to passed pawns okay that was nice
finish took work it took some mistake
from my opponents but yeah Knight c5 I
think it's winning you know I could try
and do this but then f5 it should be
winning I think
okay back to tournaments
to 81 so what do I need to get to the
top hundred oh man I'm not gonna find
out okay I need to win more games play
you for oh the box is look it up it
there should be a Wikipedia Wikipedia
article it's when the king is trying to
catch a passed pawn and the king is in
like this box then yeah it's hard to
explain
especially in the opening it's an end
game concept the King trying to catch a
passed pawn play d4 yeah this is a
trendy sort of line
I think magnus carlsen invented this
line there should be two and castling
three and then maybe g4 first always
play King b1 and the structure is pretty
solid like I'm not scared of getting
mated so soon can maybe trade off
bishops I'll start with this I just want
to do this and eventually mate
yeah this is interesting play this move
also 9a for the center is usually better
sharp position we're both trying to
attack I think I want to take and Queen
h6 and then Nathan h7 I take first just
ignore the fact that my knight is
hanging it's interesting probably not
good though yeah I want to go crazy 93
so that's going to have some initiative
Queen f6 a4 but it's a fights
not sure what the plan should be I mean
I have Knight c4 always take on g6 g5 if
I want to just distract the Queen I
could take on d6 hmm trying to calculate
Queen James d6 a three-night c4 Knight
b6 e 5 she looks okay I'm paranoid after
one of the those earlier games are just
missing maiden 1 so I have to be like
hyper aware of blacks ideas
okay now the a file is open but I'm not
getting made it on b2 which was a
concern of black lady 3 and I am up a
pawn not that much not that material is
so like relevant and in this position
the Knights attacked so Knight moves so
this could be a threat of taking on b3
so what to do Queen d4 I think I want to
trade Queens
also play some other moves let's play
Queen d4 if efile I'll be very happy so
the Queen is cut off and I'll have the
d5 square for the knight and we get into
an endgame I mop up on e5 okay this
should bring me happiness but where
should I move my queen I could take on
before it's greedy but it's a free pawn
I want to play Knight d5 the queen can't
really be attacked with rook b8 I take
on a5 it's hard for black to the Velo
like if this tonight doesn't have any
squares bishops tied down to the night
Brooks tied down to other Knights Queen
not doing anything okay life is good 95
incoming and a box was stuck Wow so
going insane
so I'm up a Knights and a pawn can
always play Bishop c4 probably not here
I could take a another piece I think
I'll start with this move the Queen
doesn't have too many squares Queen
moves here I fork Queen moves here I can
for guaranteed fork night c7 the triple
fork I'll take on a six with the night
controlling the BH square kind of
important
there should be five looks nice so I'm
up two pieces and a pawn uh what to do
probably I should move more quickly
Knight should return rook h2 is useful
move your rook yeah so the rook is now
doing a job work d6 looks nice uh what
to do Queen c4 getting out of the pin
it's take and actually Queen c4 creator
the pin - that's nice King f8 is this
maiden one that's mates that was nice
unlimited rice pudding thanks for
subbing yeah I think and thirteen months
I appreciate that
okay that was interesting game felt like
I I'm in amaizing J's which which is
important
okay play playing aggressively against
English II for efore I'll just develop
have some weird reverse Kings gambit
what is something maybe someone can
explain what is something oh this is
interesting so it takes can also take on
f2 it's a center for trick considering
night at six just allowing takes let's
do that just giving white options in
some way I'm just stacking upon take
stakes I'll be down upon but I'll have
development in a relatively open
position and Hammer hammer approves with
2x Slams
I doubt this is any sort of opening
theory can I take and just have fun I
want to have fun of Queen d4 - of Knight
some knight moves probably this move how
does white defend f2 I guess I'll find
out can defend it with the Queen usually
the queen and the king that are the
worst offenders d4 could I could take up
on Bishop e3 coming
Bishop III there's a funny line where
white just gets double pawns all over
the place I don't think I knew that but
now I know that okay let's have some fun
with White's pawn structure and trade
everything I could also take first maybe
I'll take first I don't think it makes a
huge difference
King comes to e7 yeah some beautiful
structure here the plan is this this guy
have to pretty healthy pawn islands
White has four I want to call it
unhealthy kind of grotesque I mean
mainly the double pawns it'll be fun to
snack on in the future but it still
takes work it is equal material
okay so pawn chain oh there's efore so
e4 I can win the c4 pawn I could
counter-attack
I'll just win upon
so no more double pawns for whites
that's a move
I have Bishop a6
yeah the bishop actually does an
interesting job defends upon and
controls f1 so if I just double up on
that file I can't really contest it
maybe I'll start with rook DX I'm gonna
wreck a fates I want to play roof D to
work f2 no idea what that means but I'll
take that as a compliment
let's take a pawn or at least attempt to
could also go 4G 5g 4G 5g for mm-hmm I
mean there's so many ways to continue
I'll start with g5 I want to do this and
this mmm each five
[Music]
it's nice I can like take time I don't
have to worry too much about like
flagging because there's increments have
time to drink tea there's some pressure
here what to do you rook rook c2 just
going after the C pawn okay I shouldn't
get too low on time just speed it up a
little bit
defending the pawn if work III rook c1
[Music]
interesting
I should probably fight for the D file
yeah let's do this that's annoying
though
oh I don't want to deal with this what
to do maybe g4o g4 is just terrible move
but I'll try and make it work no I just
I'm self-destructed okay I can take here
I still control f1 who to do maybe this
move oh this is really dangerous
like actually really dangerous to not
let the pawn promote get some King
activity oh dear
reroute the bishop oh no no oh this is
so sad
how is so much better White's pawns were
so ugly what happened I'm down a rook
but I have a queenside majority I have
active rook
I'm trying to fight I'm trying free pawn
hmm like free pawns aha okay I've three
connected passed pawns and oh that's not
gonna help but I still have three
connected pass pawns to push them baby
that's not gonna work though unless it
can work it's not gonna work
it's so sad I'm so close to queening
everything No
oh that's a nice move house-made into my
pawns were so beautiful there goes my
reading but I'm still still above 2500
that's really sad lost my thread in the
end game I'm joining a game okay
comeback time what to do here b5 do
something aggressive c5
see 4b 4d boss thanks for the comment
let's play do I play here may 5 is
complete development no need to spend so
much time I think that's my problem
I've been second-guessing myself too
many times we just have to play natural
moves save time especially a position
like this now it's time to take might
should return here someday any fives
good move it stick my knight wants to
come to c5 positional game and
eventually d3 and fork stuff yeah that
defense I can take first Queen b7 what
is this I want to play g5 I shouldn't
get too excited let's play 94 94 it
looks nice
I really want to take on d4 I also
really want to play g5 still I have to
resist
I'll just improve our rook mindo rush
rook d3 rook d3 h6 being patient I think
yeah I think the plan is to put the
knight on f5 also unleashing the Queen
h4 maybe my opponent was scared of g5 so
we could trade rooks how do i attack
that knight on f3 okay let's take once
and now what I like my setup I don't
want to like move anything away from any
square but I guess I have to g5 now prom
is a king just moves
okay I have a plan 94 o 94 rip t7 okay
different plan Queen eight I'm gonna
plate rook to e8 just get rid of this
rook ah but then there's might see six
issues so I'll revert to this plan I
want to bring the light to see five
targets um potential victims oh I forgot
yeah I could take bishop is loose but
the rook is currently attacked Bishop f6
I'm fighting it's equal material White's
probably better at least my pieces kind
of make sense
that's a move what to do I should
probably take the knight and then Rick
here Oh actually wait am i winning
because of this Queen's overworked I
just take b2 and the Queen i8 is being
very useful white resigns I was not
expecting to win that so abruptly Wow
might be free might be free is a move I
wanted to play but I got distracted with
other good moves
alright that was nice yeah this Queen on
eight should not be taken for granted
all right I'm the man I've not played a
London in a long time
let's play Queen's Gambit ooh
9 f6 I think my opponent was expecting
Bishop f4 maybe I don't know what is
this gambit just up a pawn and I have
centered pawns looks reasonable but yeah
okay black gets some development I don't
think I'm too afraid
yeah black actually has no Center pawns
what to do efore but that hangs d4
um is there a threat there is no threat
I should not be thinking just a three I
want to play b4 maybe be five and then
later efore okay queen of sixes idea now
h3 now the bishop can't retreats black
has to make some concession at Bishop e6
I fork and now I can get an e4 safely do
you have a favorite tournament you've
played favorite tournament I mean every
tournament in st. Louis is incredible
the st. Louis chess club actually my
favorite tournament in st. Louis was the
first time I played there in 2009 I
qualified for the u.s. junior closed by
winning the US Junior Open as a lowest
rated player by a few hundred points
everyone in the event was over 2400 I
was mid 2,200 they gave all the
participants new laptops they gave like
food stipend like sweet and like hotel
for the two weeks or whatever gave us
tickets to like a tennis match it was
amazing and I did well in the tournament
finished with four and a half out of
nine okay I got distracted for a moment
there the position is still pretty good
up upon I have some nice nice looking
pawns go play this move
is that necessary though let's play this
move maybe I'll win another pawn now e6
maybe this first and these pawns are so
majestic maybe six was just devastation
the bishops can be lost
wait your username is isn't because of
the move Knight b3
oh it's maybe because Knights have
freedom probably just yeah okay that was
nice
let's move the game so yeah it takes a
while to like work work the way up who's
in first and these scores are crazy
ooh playing an IM higher rated haven't
had too many games where my opponent is
higher rated i'll bezerk back this will
be sofia fights try to think while
opening i'll play d5 okay
yeah main line
yeah this is a sharp variation take see
796 Bishop c4 Queen eight five key to
bonk loud there's rook t1 immediately
let's take first a3 is gonna happen I'll
reposition the Queen on h5 maybe ninety
six now Queen h5 so King f1 I have nine
a five and attacking everything he's
still not a five
Brooksie seven ideas it should be okay
have Bishop d5 if necessary Queen B one
I might be free coming I could take on
d3 two I will so many juicy looking
options well it's just to improve a
bishop keep my options open
that's some move let's play Bishop here
first counter attacking the Queen Queen
c2 or that might be free might be free I
guess I want to play a5 a4 Wow
efore what's going on here oh this is
bullets I have to move quicker thanks
for subbing suboptimal it's my bishop
trapped never mind
what's going on here no on time finding
work c151 planet stocks it hey I flagged
him I was not even looking at time okay
so I won that and I got this desert
points too I'm a messy game chess
friendship or the wholesome name uh
let's not bezerk let's play this let's
say hi to just add blue hello just add
blue I'll play Bishop c4 e6 prevent e5
I'll play each four blocks kind of
playing a hippo have to poach the hippo
what to do is each six is a move
hmm I could take on a gamba the pawn
let's gather the pawn donating the d4
pawn and hopes for something in return
Oh No ah okay just have to respond to
one thing okay Oh c3 so I have I'm down
the pawn but I have some attack h6
usually the rule is with this tension
you should leave it unless taking or
pushing is really good eh six looks nice
Bishop g5 I'll play Bishop g5 attacking
the Knights all the minor pieces are
developed black has the whole Queen side
undeveloped f6 was expected I kind of
want to sack of bishop I play Bishop III
sacking another pawn just gonna sack all
the pawns and hope it's mates or hope to
trap the Queen
ah what to do rook b1 yeah rook e1 the
pawn sacking continues at some point I
have to justify this in Bishop c5 knight
c6 is kind of an issue so what to do h6
I want to play Bishop and Bishop c5
knight c6 looking for ways to generate
threats g4 g5 I want to put the bishop
on c4 so there's this move there's some
logic behind that I felt like I almost
mouse slips there but okay rook before
idea is to put the bishop aligned with
the Queen and with the king
I think I'll start with this and queen
is short on squares her okay for could
be coming actually there's a line Queen
a 3 R okay for Queen B - Rick a2 and the
Queen I think is trapped
am I just wrapping the Queen might be
trapping the Queen Queen d2 only move
there's rook ta but I just hick with a
rook a nice little Queen trap
that's a game of cat and mouse the mouse
was the queen the cow is all of these
things okay
plenty of time now e6 is a target
probably a Bishop c5 to use the Bishop
to its full potential
Queen c2 g4
it's always a nice having more material
it means there's more material to attack
with miss bishops tied down to the pawn
envisioning this this this and then I
can take the knight okay let's start
with g4
I might end up sacking like takes and
then I'm envisioning some Knight g5 sack
it looks too delicious to turn down
let's do it
cuz I'll win g6 probably almost King f6
is played King f6 how do I win that h7
what to do here I'll repeat once Bishop
b1 searching repeat again that move this
way this time not getting anything not
getting what I want that's kind of sad
I'll play Queen e2 I still have
attacking resources this time yeah this
time if this I have Queen a3 and Bishop
c1 mating in the end okay that's a move
let's play Knight g5 I take on e5 be
fancy
there's no time to calculate I'll just
win material
oh there's ninety three so I'm losing
material that's not my plan oh but I'm
winning material because I win the rook
Queen f6 is stronger if King g7 f king
g7 Queen f6
let's take here somewhat messy finish
there's some discovery but I'm not
scared of it so c4
I'm threatening mate in one
there we go okay Oh a little bit low on
time that that's what happens okay back
on a streak have a rough patch for a
moment there are you going to play the
rest of the marathon time will tell
oh I played him before forget what we
played before let's play something new
knight c6 d6 another like Carlsen
opening hey Knight f6 okay
appearance defense I'm not booked up
here I see five is natural I could
Castle I could take an H five could be a
move yeah I should probably have studied
this position more d5 looks wrong I'll
play that h5 looks interesting not sure
what I've accomplished
maybe a six it's not the most impressive
opening play yeah a g4 I play this
before maybe that somehow it works
there's many lines d4 hangs in the end I
will say it's hard to constantly watch
chat while playing but sometimes I'll
glance at chat but it's not easy during
a tournament also not easy like I've
been streaming for about forget maybe
four or five hours total today streamed
for a good portion of time this morning
okay let's stay focused h6 is probably
the way to go we could trade rooks on
the H file I could play this with an
Bishop d5 hah what to do
maybe Knight a5 looks very strange but
it's a move I just want to play this and
Knight c4 so I'm doing the same thing on
both flanks I played now h5 to f4
earlier I'm doing basically the same
thing on the Queen side so there's some
symmetry which is one of the ways to
create beauty let's take take some more
things yeah return the bishop to its
home c5 might be thematic also defend my
Knights
maybe c6 defending a knight and
attacking a knight I see the comments
about chess coaching I've yeah I've been
a chess coach since high school for
about seven seven to eight years
recently there's been so much demand and
I've been so busy with so many things
that it's been hard to take students but
I'm in the process of like trying to
restructure my approach to private
lessons but yeah life is hectic ie five
is scary
I think I should play Knight c4 sooner
rather than later
see if I wants to trade off the bishop
interesting it's a very weird game so
far whoo 94 is gonna probably hurt me do
I have Queen b6 Queen b6 9a for Queen b5
there's also beat three Queen B 4 this
is a scary position I can take on d6 to
a 94 so much initiative for whites so
let's try this
I want the taste of initiative
yeah b3 good move and now Bishop e6 oh
no did I just blunder d5 d5 I do have
Queen a5 it gets really weird D 5.85
takes take
that might be a stronger move I have
Bishop f6 ice looking maybe take should
I throw and take takes let's try it and
try and make white think now Bishop f6
[Music]
od5 I can take on c3 maybe
oh that's very hurtful on bishops just
trapped I do have this move though this
is gonna be so painful
what's my have any last hope I guess
Queen here Queen here defends the
obvious threats I'll play King f8
probably hmm v f6 always play off 6 this
Bishop is so depressed 3 seconds white
having over a minute not a pleasant
situation but I'm alive still kind of on
the play Bishop f7 wrong run the King
and survive yeah I'm gonna lose c6 but
then I'll have a half-open C file
be queen a5 I need counterplay not sure
if that generates enough counterplay
though wait what
take a free rook free rook I like free
rooks some nice early Christmas presents
but I'm not out of the danger zone yet
yeah this is still really terrifying but
I think I'm alive also I have a pastel
font so I'm threatening to take the
Queen there's quite a 7 let's play this
move I always play Bishop f8 if I win
this it's it's a miracle
ooh free bishop I'll just move back not
getting mated oh but I'm losing it's ok
this is fine or is it oh no I messed
this up not sure what the ending
yeah what's happening in the ending ok
this should be fine though the pawn will
push to its glory
check hey bishop here I want to mate on
a one
interesting these checks are kind of
annoying
please stop checking me oh no am I
getting her pet fur cutted no Queen c7
no I really getting per petted no that's
a Christmas tragedy Oh Queen c7 opponent
moved too quickly there why am I saying
Christmas Halloween uh okay that was a
wake-up call what does this game this
game is such a crazy game let's be
careful
keep the pawn defended yeah now I'm
trying to promote Queen e5 it's fine
here we go
wait how do I win let's take a pond oh
no there's checks again oh not this
again
okay I'm gonna run with the king
I run far distances okay
King safety are these checks keeps
finding the weirdest checks okay safety
promotions coming free Queen yes what a
game
I can't was ridiculous I mean I was dead
I was so long time earlier my point gave
me a free rook then had perpetual but
messed it up slightly that was
ridiculous how do you avoid tilt tea and
deep breath yeah it was a pleasant gift
of the free rook and then another gift
of not propelling me yeah I think at
this point it's just perpetual Queen a6
but Queen a6 is necessary opponent got
you comfortable want to break into the
top 200
I would like to 200 total tournament
points there's a lot of teas
that game was about I think it was
around 80 moves oh maybe I was saying
Christmas because it was a lot of gifts
okay
oh and what to do let's play e4 okay
Halloween time I think my last Halloween
gambit I lost so this is time for
redemption
d5 best move I think I've studied this
but I forgot what to do
maybe I just take I take with Bishop and
there's like Bishop b4 kc6 looks like a
move yeah the goal is just to brag about
my beautiful center pawns castle idea
that f4 f5 not f5 coming but do I care I
kind of care wait 94 idea of c3 also
idea of 96 multi-purpose I can play off
for now it's a nice formation f5 is idea
to almost traps tonight yes there's 97
f5 while I want to play C 4 F 5 is
actually probably a good move because I
don't want to take on pissant even
though it might be the best move
thinking Knight g3
I'll play Knight g3 because now my
Center pawns are pretty pretty stable
and I play c4 and just keep expanding
like a trademark Halloween gambits down
a piece but the pawns are compensation
but now what do I do
black wants to play Bishop g7 and Castle
I have a d5 maybe Rock a 500k five the
rook is a bit loose so what to do H 5 H
4
I'm not seeing a clear plan I mean let's
play Queen f3 rook d1 and then try some
day for d5 maybe okay this is my plan
put all the pieces to prepare the d5
push King f7 unexpected pretty sure
black yeah a lot could legally castle
there and black is castling by hand okay
so I'm executing my plan in hopes of
executing my opponent I have upon d5 now
d5 supported now this is nice nice
formation
I want to play Knight b5 soon at some
points unless this is played so there's
a 6 or d6 or doing something else what
to do
Bishop c5 Bishop c5 before think with
the dark side Bishop my pawns are
happier in light squares interesting so
II 6 here or b4 first trying to
calculate but it's difficult you rook
there go play rook d3 it seems like a
random move but I want to double up
support the D pawn I'm pretty sure if
takes rook t1 should win back material
38 seconds
yeah before is called for now maybe e6
yeah II 66 my pawns are rolling like a
bowling ball these are my pins hey it's
a sub Deadman DM thanks for subbing
again 15 months and the pawns and these
pawns feel so good I don't want to lose
them and I'm guaranteed to win something
cuz if the knight moves east sevens of
fork yeah let's play you seven I don't
even want to take the bishop but maybe I
should I'm conflicted yeah let's just
take the bishop the proper decision
maybe this move b5 now this might is a
bit awkward if it moves back it cuts off
the defense of the rook and I can take
on b6 so as a knight just trapped if it
moves back either way I take on b6 the
night might just be trapped yeah
apologies for the twitch lag' hopefully
it wasn't too bad
I should be not lagging anymore I think
that's one of the symptoms of jet lag
rook f6 okay
went from being down the piece to being
up a piece and now just winning more
stuff out two pieces well the game was a
nice game
like a very classic Halloween
gambit game maybe I'll upload this I'll
post this on Halloween this will be my
Halloween video if I remember to find it
what's my uptime I'll find it somehow
yeah for people watching on Halloween if
I don't get around to making an even
better Halloween video there's your
Halloween video for 2019 smash the like
button tell me what you're dressed up as
and I'll see you in the future oh I
should I should design a nice thumbnail
that's true I need to find the costume
or I just need to photoshop myself it's
probably more efficient
okay back to tournaments ooh close to
200 I think the goal is to finish in the
top 100 or the top 10 but that's kind of
far away still let's play chess let's
play Budapest I'm feeling a little bit
of tiredness but I'm still kind of awake
flour 91 okay we have a position that
I've had a good number of times before
this is a the typical Budapest middle
gameplan just lifting the rook and
gaining muscle
a story I think f4 is probably like the
best approach and now I'm a little bit
scared of things not sure where to put
the Knights guess I'll put it there
I wear shoe says make long YouTube
videos posting majority of streams
please they are nice to watch while I do
work curious what sort of work you do
where you're watching and multitasking
yeah the thing with posting long streams
is there are big file sizes and I
usually do a little bit of editing but
I'll take that into consideration I
Pilon I'm posting all of this to YouTube
at some point
Bishop D for Saudi for what to do
roti 6 it's weird the rook usually does
not belong in front of the centre pawn
in the middle game but it's aligned with
the Queen and I was threatening work
takes III maybe now I can play b6 so the
rook has migrated from a 8 to d6 I'm
ready to play Bishop e7 I still want to
attack like there should be seven Knight
h4 and the arrows will do the work c5
yeah see fives probably accurate I could
take I should probably take thinking of
sacking bishops annoying me but what
else to do
maybe rook c6 it's interesting line
Bishop b5 pawn takes pawn
Bishop takes and then takes I think it
works in this line too I mean I'm gonna
lose or I'm gonna win or it's gonna be a
draw but I lost my rook but okay I have
I have invincible pawn now on e3 it'll
be invincible until it's captured or
until it's promoted what's material I
have I have two pawns for the exchange I
could push this pawn it will be like the
previous game oh that would be fun
anything I mean d5 I have to be careful
of weaknesses D 5 D for White's pieces
are better than mine my pieces are just
garbage right now
hmm
I don't see anything concretely wrong
with this it's just I'm overextending
and White's pieces are they're gonna
start attacking me but as long as I can
keep the center pawns and eventually
checkmate everything will be okay so
yeah d4 or maybe maybe I should start
with Bishop a6 oh no I can't
okay I'll do this ah
so if Queen c4 oh never mind okay let's
stop talking and let's start playing or
first start thinking takes Bishop d3 it
makes sense I want to play Bishop a6 so
I want to play d3 it takes
they're running short on time time
management has not been good this game
Bishop is very short on squares
at least holding on to d3 or up to e3 oh
but not anymore
oh no we have six I guess some hope of
Queen d4 working this is my one lifeline
Queen b6 ideas I've been in the
situation before yeah so Queen b6 I want
to play Bishop c5 this is a plan Bishop
c5 to d4 and c5 oh I have to defend my
rook I have 2.0 seconds but sadly the
Queen's are getting traded this is not
gonna end well no oh this is really sad
there's no not even any like still
matrix
I'm just getting maded next move all
that my opponent may me deserves it I
was rough it was like very much like a
Halloween gambit except my pieces just
were not lively yeah
maybe I had to do a different approach
not sure what
oh maybe there should be a six
immediately because rookie one I have
bishop before but opponent played well
kudos doctor tournaments for hours one
minute and 50 seconds left Grandmaster
Gauri and the chats are master Gauri are
you playing the tournament are you just
watching feel like watching is probably
a lot less stressful
I played Gauri over the summer or no it
was when did we play was it may I play
the London against him we drew in less
than 10 moves okay so London opening a
fight for something here reverting to my
bread and butter to play against knight
c6 I mean the clear intention is Pawnee
595 expecting Bishop takes okay this is
interesting to play f4 you'll start with
this okay this looks reasonable I like
playing against the structure ePHI while
the structure is transforming there's
ninety five stuff maybe I should just
Castle soon
I should probably castle soon
there's a three to apply a three with a
three I'm trying to provoke Bishop takes
d2 so that after Queen takes d2 I can
recapture the Queen on g4 that way the
e-file stays closed my king will be safe
I was initially hesitant to play this
because after takes takes Knight c5 wait
no that doesn't work because I just take
yeah I am I'm suffering from some
fatigue the position is reasonable I
think I have the bishop hair loss upon
tension so things could open up soon or
things could close down soon let's take
with the pawn yeah I think is opening up
my throw and c5 okay block throws it in
first back three looks nice pinning the
D pawn um if I take there's ninety five
let's take with the Queen first Oh Gauri
slept at 7 a.m. today woke up with 11
not healthy guess what time I woke up
today maybe I said it already I woke up
at 2 was it 2:30 sometime like 2:30 or
3:00 a.m. I've been awake since but I
got I got like 7 hours of sleep I'm
pretty jet-lagged okay
get away with this I think I can get
away with this Griff d1 the pawn is
pinned in two directions
so if Knight takes e4 Queen takes e4 a5
is interesting after f5 all use this
resource and win a pawn eventually
and maybe lose it back I'm very thankful
to have this move and then rookie 5 so I
hold on IBG g3
there's also Bishop e2 I'm just taking
advantage of like all these tactics I
want to play F 4 and then cement
everything like the pawn will defend the
rook which defends upon which control
space so yeah it defend the pawn first
oh I had this move maybe that move could
have maybe one material and servers work
f7 it's also maybe Rupp takes d5
complicated everything is more
complicated when you are tired just a
nature of life let's improve the King I
want to play Bishop b5 soon but not now
play g3 if they trial opens I'm happy
Oh Gauri is playing in Charlotte nice
what to do
I could take free pawn everything in
life is free do I take first then we
trade I probably have to take though
what else to do
what should do they should eat - the
bishop is kind of pinned to the pawn so
I have a a queen side and the King side
majority I'm up two pawns it still takes
work to win blacks works are tied down
can I just push an a pawn
maybe King III first looks like a small
improvement and yeah I should trade
rooks this looks fine
oh there's a b2 is kind of weak tickled
the bishop oh there's a nice idea
actually I attack the pawn oh wait I'm
hallucinating I thought that rook was
gonna be on b5 so I could play b4 just
pure hallucination so I have to grind
down this end game let's take up on
interesting oh I forgot about that okay
it's tricky now and I'm still playing
for a win a g5 yeah it's gonna be a draw
sadly that's my opponent goes insane I
have actually interesting idea now no la
the Chiemsee get closer it's still a
draw though yeah so this is my idea oh
wait please play a check please please
please Oh wrong check so yeah just to
show my idea I was trying to create a
situation where black could actually
over push which I've seen happen before
if Locke checks like this this and then
the hope is that black plays King here
thinking it's winning but then white has
one move to survive and then white
should be winning so I'll give time give
people time if you're watching on
YouTube in the future you want to pause
the video to find the move for whites
I've shown this to students and
sometimes it takes them a while
good job diamond cutter Queen h8 is a
winning move so that's what I was hoping
for just why I allowed the Black team
King to get a little bit closer but okay
back to tournament I didn't lose still
208 playing swoll Oh follow streamer
but he's not streaming I don't think
it's likeif or shadow it's a swole do I
play a Halloween I feel like I should
mix it up it's like Spanish yo quiero yo
quiero ganar el partido el partido so
you have a game yeah I don't really
speak much Spanish I know the opening a
lot more than I know the language I
don't really know the opening not much
let's play h3 and I know the and there's
usually two main approaches y can play
d3 or ad for I'll play d4 usually I want
to play d5 yeah I thought allows I'd see
for a while I'd see for let's play b3
and I'll do the typical Spanish Knight
maneuver
and there's some eventual plan of just
doing things on the kingside c4 so c4
the idea is to play a five maybe four a
five could be annoying so I could allow
it I could ignore it
what to do I just want to sleep before I
think will play before I'll just kind of
let it happen and then ignore everything
just take back maybe a three at some
points might be free
thanks for the bits the wake up bits do
you need to wake up a little bit play
this move yeah I mean not f5 is usually
the dream g6 crushes my dream can play
Bishop g5 yeah I'm trying to attack
graph three could be nice rook a3 is
interesting okay three stops Queen f3
but then Rick III what does this move
that's a move interesting move takes
takes
I'm losing a pond sadly nice move okay I
think I see a way to get some comp to
just enter with the Queen
bring the Knight to g5 inmates because
darts where's our a week if King here
maybe a Queen g5 is d5 d5 looks
threatening let's take up on opening up
the e4 square it's all about darks for
an action I have a light shower disap
which isn't the most useful but the
Knights will be useful and so will the
Queen maybe the bishop afore this looks
Pleasant I have a secret threats but I
want to say it as opponent might be
watching also there might not be a
secret threat I might be bluffing I'll
just let my opponent think and try and
figure out the secret threat I'm only
down one pawn I have everything almost
everything on the Kings side or directed
at the Kings side the arrow is alone
aren't just terrifying so my secret
threat was Knight h5 I think this is
winning unless it's not winning but I
mean it looks so fun
single-file line on h-file also the okay
the pawn is pinned in two directions
that spin to the Queen and more
importantly to the each sudden pawn I'm
threatening made in one if not a five I
just take it the King can't run they
can't hide yeah that was a nice finish
no he played well like I think Knight
takes d5 is very strong but lack has to
be very careful here I was looking at
this King g7 Queen here and then each
six it's maybe a better approach and it
would get weird I would do stuff there's
also like this maneuver black should
play a bit safer GG swoll in the chat
shout-out to swoll you guys can also
follow him on Twitch I so swole 19 okay
playing per harsh 1999 every buzzer - in
a while alright let's play let's play
aggressively I don't know what opening
I'm gonna play I'll play a molar attack
because why not
I haven't played a molar attack in a
long time
I'll see if my opponent knows theory
yeah I think of opponent knows theory
but we'll see how much Theory castling
casting is not usually the most played
move attacking the night expecting 97
after which I'll play Bishop f5
nights be free asking question oh let's
not hang a piece like there's a d3
threatening I want to play this I don't
want to lose my rook c5 this is getting
weird
he'll play d6 pawn d6 just what we need
one I don't have much time though each
four let's play pawn to d6 it was a
question was your Asia trip a complete
vacation yeah it was mainly vacation I
have some friends who were in between
jobs and it was very it was pretty
spontaneous planned it like a week or
two before but it was nice but I'm happy
to be back and trying to rebuild my
routines okay I have a secret thread of
queenie 4 with a double fork all forks
are at least double forks ooh
not sure which thing to do let's do this
thing and I'll win the rook there's my
g5 the g5 takes takes I can't resist
it might be wrong but it might be right
let's take care now
okay so I'm up but I'm also down on time
21 seconds I'm up the exchange okay I do
want to simplify rook p1 is a must
that's scary want to plants the bishop
on e7 and grow a tree jib g5 yeah there
should be g5 busy b7 maybe f4 f5 coming
some day inspecting rook c6 cam
pressuring the bishop ending this also
h4 h5 some day night t2 would be
incredibly tricky
now there's f5 it's a five work almost
kind of works let's pretend it doesn't
work I wanna play h5 now stopping my
plan oh now I have a meeting idea a very
simple mating idea to do this and then
meet
ten seconds plenty of time right my
mighty - could be annoying quitting the
fork okay that's what I was expecting
okay plenty of time
I shouldn't fall below three seconds
okay I took efforts and it's difficult
not having increments I didn't have
increment because I desert it cuts your
time in half and it takes away the
precious increment but got the job done
that was important shoulder out the
black king and the King pawn ending top
200 let's go
do I bezerk again probably not though
I'll play aggressively or at least try
to play aggressively
I'll play the ooh we have a we have a
Belgrade gambit might be 4 is supposed
to be the best move against the Belgrade
it's weird but it's a computer
recommendation
buzzer King gives you extra tournament
points so if you're on a streak then and
you win after buzzer King it gives you
five points rather than four I don't
want to stress myself out too much and
maybe let's just move back so I mop up
on life is good
there's a g5 interesting I want to play
this but Bishop d3
this should be okay
I think h6 after Bishop d3 age 65 Queen
h5 what's the best way to learn theory
everyone has different learning styles
so it's about understanding your own
learning style and then finding the
resources at best accommodate your
learning style g5 but yeah in terms of I
assume you're referring to opening
theory
I mean chess table is popular these days
and there's good old-fashioned opening
books there's also a difference between
like choosing what openings to play and
then memorizing lines if you're trying
to choose like your repertory then like
studying the games of players who you
admire it's not a bad idea and seeing
what they play in the opening double
fianchetto still up a pond it's probably
going to win it back like Bishop b4 or a
bishop before it's probably a very good
move here
I'll probably end up queenside castling
wait takes you have takes I take back
with pong I'll teach the D file well B
for some confusing position kind of
makes my head hurt
I could play uh yeah let's just bring
the final piece into the game
we have ripka asking a question I know
what you're referring to it's not a
quality white would be better there
let's play Knight a5 not the most
beautiful move yeah rook an idea the
problem with night 84 is the line with
f3 but I'll save that for another day
what did you hear d6 maybe to make my
bishop happy I'm trying to win upon the
threat might be g4 unleashing the Queen
removing the Knights f5 here are five
just takes a queen g6 Queen g6 queen g4
check
Oh
what to do he's still G for the pawn is
pinned in two directions pin by the rook
and pinned by the bishop as well some
idea of playing out five soon it is nice
having Crimmins
Knight c5 would run into queen eights it
should be slightly tragic yeah I think
I'm just winning a pawn
yes 94-94 take with bishop try and
simplify I mean light squares are very
weak make c6 is just a massive hole
the Queen c6i Brooke c5 also whites
about to flag okay now when I see five
just try and keep applying pressure Wow
opponent flags okay I'll take that
climbing up 186 shatter play something
new let's play a whatever this is the
been defying will defense I know Ben has
a lot of videos covering this this
defenses black they call it like was it
the check Benoni or the Benoni wall
something benoni G for the g4 so one
plan is to play b5 but how to execute it
maybe just a six I want to play b5 soon
white doesn't want me to play b5 it's
not nice
well it's maybe sinks have to kind of
slowly prepare it really not sure what
to do and just feel short on space not a
good position for a claustrophobic
maybe I'll fee and kettle my rook and
then I'll do this and then this and then
this and then this and everything will
be aimed at b5 it meanwhile light will
do stuff I'm staying within the first my
first two rings but at least I have a
plan
I'm operating in low space g5 might come
like weeny eights discouraging g6 I
might want to play at five soon five
could be nice oh let's start with her p7
Wow all those arrows I do earlier
everything came true I got my pieces I
have how many supporters one two three
four supporters all targeting b5 do I
play it now or do I play f6f-5 maybe f5
a5 is interesting
and the two main pawn breaks in the
structure are a 5 and B 5 it's looking
like I'll get in both by the 5 I just
take it Bishop g5 ok
B 5 time position is becoming a bit more
comfortable
rook a8 trying to make me uncomfortable
have this move some battery against f2
so I'm threatening to take and win a
pawn I also have ideas of taking open
the B file this rook doesn't scare me
yet what's my favorite time control
depends on my mood yeah I'd like rapid
chess so anything below 15 minutes my
least favorite time control are those
like long long ones where you get like
extra time after you move 40 the game
can go up to 6 hours not a fan of those
[Music]
yeah let's open the B file don't quite
understand why White's act the rook for
the night ok what to do
I'll play Bishop a4 give the dish of a
purpose in life the goal is to remove
the the knight from defending the pawn
so I can win the pawn and check me at
the king I guess the issue is that after
takes takes the Queen defends upon hmm I
could still take this move also looks
interesting
just attack laterally rook was hanging
rook was hanging oh I had a knight move
was a rook hanging was the knight was on
c7 the whole time
Knight c7 wow I just didn't see that I
can move into the corner it's just a
blind spot it's like something you just
I saw 59 squares I just didn't see wait
how many squares are on a chessboard
I saw 63 squares I didn't see the 64th
square okay let's play let's not mouse
slip
well I could play this move too so many
moves ok let's take the thing the
Knights attacked ooh but now things are
attacked in my position I have a g6
what's that song like a g6 not even sure
if that means Bishop e2 let's attack her
Brooke
such a weird position pieces are all
over the place working on the flanks I
could take the rook but that's probably
bad play Bishop d7 centralizing some
date Bishop h3 will happen whoa
King f7 okay now I can take the knight I
can also take upon pawns are sometimes
more valuable than Knights Knights
pinned to that fun check check
then I'll take the Knights feel like I
missed a lot of things this game Bishop
b5 someday we work here mmm what's the
simplest approach Bishop e5 okay
checkmate
okay got the job done rating has been
staying around the same place for a
while we just would not make a good pets
because it fails to fetch all right
let's play a Queens gambit declined
Cambridge Springs
oh my neck is sore I didn't realize how
sore my neck was until I looked up ouch
okay I could play play this move I'll go
for the the quick attack
Queen b3 is a move and c5 looks the
matic maybe takes I'll take a 95 I have
a bishop pair yeah let's just play
positionally I'll take gained a tempo on
the rook and castle and bring the bishop
back Oh II four is gonna happen
efore a5 there's b5 I mean what else do
I do though yes I'll do this se5 is a
the approach huh Queen c2 let's just
swing over now the Knights tied down to
defending against mates I still want to
play e5 also idea this and this I'll
start with b6 useful move anyway
undermining the rook
this could be a long game thinking I
might like play queen g6 we trade Queens
I try and within the endgame with the
two bishops yeah safety first
he 594 is a problem play Bishop c2 it
should be seven yeah this Bishop is
still hibernating someday it will come
to life
maybe Bishop a6 was a consideration why
wants to play c5 which is very
reasonable
maybe e5 now's the time open the
position yeah whenever you have the
bishop here you have to be aware of like
pawn Drake's to make the bishops happy
so now one Bishop is happy let's make a
rook happy rooks on open files have
smiles oh the pawns defended by my queen
when Bishop has mobility I mean this
diagonal or this diagonal our other
options
see five Wow
[Music]
close to winning material but not quite
this is interesting it was very
interesting I'm not going to calculate
I'm just gonna play on fuel
and intuition I'm just envisioning takes
and then takes and hopefully that works
but my neck is like it's really sore it
could be a result of my flights
I had a was it a four-hour flight
followed by a 13-hour flight wasn't the
most enjoyable experience I also had the
mill seats for the 13 hour flights and
so sore afterwards I take the pawn take
the pawn I flew from Taiwan to South
Korea to Chicago wow what is this okay
everything's attacked both bishops and
my queen are attacked and I'm low on
time and I'm down upon could be worse
but what do I do takes 36 doesn't work
bishop move Bishop d6 Bishop d6 might be
an option actually visual d6 takes takes
it's the only way to avoid the Queen
trade and I'm I'm assuming the still is
okay if takes takes I should be mating
otherwise I want to retreat the bishop
probably here and then made on each two
or even here and attack the rook let's
attack the rook Hey tactics waiting the
Queen but White's gonna win back some
material just have to knock flag
everything should be okay play Queen e4
probably rookie rookie a coming next
calculating rook be too rocky a turkey
to Queen d3 resigns
not resins okay play on a few more moves
Bishop f4 resigns or queen c1 mates
there we go
okay Bishop takes g2 as mates where was
Bishop takes g2 I wanted to do this but
Queen takes here as a problem oh do I
have this move but then Bishop takes you
to I'm not mating there but yeah this is
nice
cuz e4 it looks so natural but it cut
off the defense Bishop to Queen and
allow this there is so much geometry
like so many diagonals and ranks and
more diagonals gari saying could you
play Bishop h2 and R of T six instead of
Bishop d6 I did not consider that that's
interesting but what happens after King
takes h2 the problem is like most
discoveries allows Queen takes h6 so I
don't think that works also gari do you
want to be a VIP or mod it's your choice
over t6
oh I see what you mean and that line
though rook d6 let me analyze and show
everyone so gari was suggesting this
takes and then this but I think Y can
just take take something King takes h3
and White has a rook and two minors at a
pawn for the Queen okay I'll make gari a
VIP
unless Gauri wants to be something else
there we go okay computer oh it's a draw
wait why is it a draw perpetual oh I the
King can't escape Queen here King g3
Queen d6 also somehow Rick p8 is drawn
that's funny
that's nasty so what does computer say
here a hapa ship t6 I found the best
move and black is somehow slightly
better that's funny
growl growl growl eight
Arcanine thanks for subbing okay yeah I
got very low on time that game but I
invested my time in the the right
critical moment it's a big component in
blitz as to take time where the
decisions matter play London I'm playing
a Grand Prix hard to play London after
playing e4 I'll play the line with d4 I
played this earlier had some interesting
results
I'm still trying to remember what to do
after Queen b6 someone played this
earlier I didn't check the line but now
at least I have time to think earlier i
beserk ty had no time is it c3
what's the line here I was preparing
this for a tournament should all be
sound okay so if we think about this
logically black wants to play a six so I
have to do something
I played c3 in that previous game oh is
it my g5 because Knight g5 e six I can
take on d6 but then there's my h6 and h6
kind of does its job
hey Grandmaster garver something
appreciate that trying to figure this
out IV v e5 could be weird I mean I
might just play c3 not the most exciting
yeah I'll play c3 so this is a gambit
I'll remember to look at this this line
afterwards take with pawn last time I
took with Knight
okay I'll mix it up a little bit taking
with pawn I keep the B file open so I
might just want to play rook b1 but not
now oh there's Queen before and some
line oh this is not good
I'm losing more material Oh unless I do
this yeah this is fine I'll still be
down upon not the end of the world
I was thinking takes takes and then
Queen before but I have queen takes d4
Bishop III perhaps it's also a five here
let's play this aligning with the Queen
expecting this move and then probably
queen d3 I spent so much time in the
opening man
okay queen d3 defends everything
the Queen has over works though so this
might work but opponent doesn't go for
it play Bishop III or can i play now
knight c6 doesn't work I'll go for this
there should be 75 I'm fighting for
something Wow 94 maybe e 6 e 6 f5 if I
take I've so little time it's terrible
time management let's take first I'll
play rook c1 I want to go for f5 f5
immediately the pawns no longer attached
that's probably a good move with a bad
game
okay this move makes me happy because
now there's at least some play I'm
threading me than to actually no I'm not
fair about ninety eight but I'm
threatening stuff with Queen g5 98
immediately while okay I'll play Queen
g5 now momentum is shifting hmm looking
for crazy moves I think I'll start with
rook here Bishop is pinned
how many pawns are my down down two
pawns could be worse what does this move
that's a fancy move move very fancy
let's play this move had to defend the
knight and the rook balk doesn't have
too many options okay I don't want to
Queen trade but I'll probably have to
allow it
you bring the rook in the bishop in the
center three seconds this time
management just have to stay calm and
give back the choice what to take back
with if pawn takes Bishop e2 and b5 the
targets just gonna pretend that I'm
knocked down two pawns and just play
that endgame and g4 I'll watch a king
side pawn storm maybe this move Knight
is almost trapped but not quite trapped
yeah that's unfortunate gonna re
reposition the rook maybe target f7 hmm
as you can see for I guess go after e3
mmm this is not pleasant
I have to put the bishop on b1 that's so
sad
rookie two attacking the pawn
okay I'm gonna lose a bishop sadly still
trying to fight mmm well-played try and
gain time time losing stuff opponent in
ticket oh that's not stalemate whoa
free rook what mouseland maybe a mouse
lip it's a miracle
it's an early Halloween miracle I'm
still lost but wasn't nice gifts I'm
getting needed
hmm oh it's so close to still mates can
I take that
it's almost stalemate what's going on
take this thing is this gonna be a draw
okay it's still a fight I have some
sorts no wait no I'm gonna lose no all I
fought so hard I fought so hard I'm
sorry I Kingi five wait what
no kingi five there's this move over
thinking of six ah die half kingi five
really what is this position
kingi five I just saw Brooke age five I
thought I was losing but oh yeah no I'm
pretty sure I saw this King out six in a
row gauge six that's still losing I
think my King has drived away from its
friend kingsnakes g6 was bad oh maybe I
just saved the rook first yeah and
grandmasters in the chat
giving me reason to regret now this this
is a table based raw right oh my gosh so
many moves drawn even wait keen 66 is
drawn what kh5 yeah this is still drawn
what's oh my aching g5 King g5 oh that's
so nasty
look at this King g5 I rejected this cuz
this and then King takes rook but king
h4 king h4 and game study you like
blocks not winning and if Knight G to
Knight G to king h5 it still stalemates
this is still mates
this is still me it's everything
everything that's to me what is this
chess chess is art sometimes it's insane
this is a draw Wow oh that would have
been so nice to find I'd basically given
up here I think I'm gonna end it with
that
that's a nice finish Last Samurai
shout out to Last Samurai and fellow
streamer grandmaster so the last seven
samurai I think I spelled that correctly
my neck is sore I'm drained
I need food I need more tea I'm
jet-lagged - so I have to maybe sleep at
some point I appreciate all the
viewership really appreciate it I'm
going to export this to youtube I don't
want to download the file because it's
gonna be lots of gigabytes so I'm gonna
raid the one and only chest weed for
people watching in the future on YouTube
hope you enjoyed that for people
watching on twitch looks like chest wave
is playing the arena the rate is
beginning
oh yeah Last Samurai I'll be back in st.
Louis
most likely tomorrow actually
I'll be around this week shoot me a
message okay
Ches weed good luck to chest weed
goodbye everyone